so this is my closet of sorts PT headed
to Moncks Corner South Carolina for an
exclusive chat at home with southern
charm star Kathryn Calhoun Dennis I'm
only one telling the truth here
Catherines had her ups and downs on the
Bravo hitch but she says season four
will be different I think that people
will be surprised at how easygoing and
normal that I can be you know I'm not
acting all crazy you know flipping
people the finger although I wanted to
several times um I don't know it's gonna
be so different and in good ways I hope
I know they're good for me but help I
know about she will go she should
this is the first thing where you were
fully sober absolutely yeah um season
one I was having fun and I was 21 right
I forget how young you were when this
all started I know and I'm 25 now it's
been wild but a great experience um yes
it's my first season watching it all
sober and that's going to be through
fresh eyes and I think that it'll
provide some new perspective probably on
these people and the situations that we
have Kathryn spent part of last year at
a treatment facility for substance abuse
how are you doing today great better
than ever you know it's been a long haul
but um I feel more me than I've ever
felt I don't I'm really at peace with
everything what I went through wasn't
just addressing you know drug alcohol
whatever it was more beneficial in like
life skills and honestly in a way I
think everyone should go to some type of
rehab because you just learned so much
about people in life and I think that's
really been key can be kidding we have
to go
really can't be there of course season
four won't be totally drama-free for the
mom of two now the babies are not here
with you right now though they're in
Cali with Thomas with Thomas why not
just take a chance let's give it a shot
it looks like he and Landon something
happens there between this something's
been happening of course and now it's
just she's got her you know moment to
move in how do you feel about that
hey you know I think they're pretty
equal so maybe they found their equals
and that's fine but she'll never be
around my children I know that I
disagree with her morals in her
lifestyle but a let'em eat cake
[Music]